this is how alasha maybe doon and his
family have been living for the past
four days
during the day he and his family sit on
any dry patch of land they can find
and at night he says they sleep on a
road not too far away
the floods have destroyed his home and
much of what was in it
and there isn't enough aid distributed
by the government to his village of
gozawa
for everyone the rains came on saturday
and flash floods flowed on sunday as the
rains continued
the water has gone down a bit but we
still don't have any dry spots
most of the villages have moved to
higher ground and were given tents
but the tents distributed weren't enough
for all of us
15 families have been left out in the
open
some families are still trying to
salvage what they can from their homes
more than 1 500 people have been
displaced in gozawa
most have moved to the west of the
village and now live in tents
but the stagnant water is raising
concerns amongst the villagers over
waterborne diseases
such as malaria and cholera and the
villagers also have other concerns
we want more tents and blankets because
the rains keep coming and we don't know
how we'll survive
here there are snakes there are
scorpions we need anti-venom serums and
first aid supplies
dozens of areas in sudan have been
affected by flooding
having lost so much already people here
say they're concerned about the coming
few months because this is just the
start of the rainy season
but this is not the first time this has
happened during every rainy season in
sudan there is often loss of lives and
properties
more than 70 people died and thousands
were displaced during last year's rainy
season
and sudan's government is now warning of
not just flash floods
but floods from the nile river which
runs through the country
a committee was set up to prepare for
this year's season but members say
some things are out of their control
then of course
there's a flat area this is of course
a problem sometimes because
the drainage is difficult with
with filat area so you need the bombs
you need special means
to drain the flow to the night
particularly when the nile is full
with news that more flooding could be on
its way and asham is worried
he says he and his family don't know how
they'll survive if more heavy rains do
come
hippo morgan al jazeera algatena white
now state